say life lesson five and this is an
important one be prepared for death
don't worry about it you can't
completely control it make sure that the
day you meet your maker is not the first
time you've been introduced if you
aren't prepared at all times you're free
to live life fearless and that was your
attitude eventually you had to say you
know what whether I'm first whether I'm
last if it's my time it's my time I can
only control so much and you know that
point was really driven home last week
when my wife passed away that uh you
know uh
she he was prepared to meet her maker I
know that
and she's in a better place today
because of that